virginia creates a time capsule so
future generations can learn just why
america collapsed and as americans
remain trapped in afghanistan covered
lockdown's bloom and culture war breaks
out everywhere the biden administration
has a new old plan throw money at all
the things i'm bench bureau this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben while joe biden is not deterred he's
going to spend more money than anyone
has ever seen and this means now is an
excellent time for you to diversify at
least a little bit into precious metals
you can see it at the pump the grocery
store and construction costs another
month of the highest inflation since
2008 another month where paper money
you're carrying around is worth less
than it was you know just a couple of
months ago so what exactly is your plan
to protect your savings you have
homeowners insurance in case of a fire
what sort of financial insurance do you
have in place if inflation sets in
further and pushes prices even higher
well part of my insurance plan gold and
silver from birch gold group if you
haven't reached out to birch gold to
diversify your ira or 401k into a
precious metals high array go ahead and
do it today text ben do 474747 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings with gold they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews thousands of
happy customers talk to them have them
help you safeguard your retirement
savings text ben to 47 47 47 you can
claim your free no obligation
information kit on holding gold and
silver in a tax sheltered account again
text ben to 47 47 47 to take the first
step in protecting your savings today
text my name ben 47 47 47 and get in
touch with my friends over at birch gold
to get started alrighty so
first of all just want to say shana to
um
all of my listeners that means have a
happy and sweet new year because the
last couple of days i was off thanks to
the jewish new year which is a time for
reflection it's a time for thought it's
a time for making new resolutions it's a
time for renewal in fact and
the good news is that
we did that in my community we spent
some time thinking about all those
things and then the bad news was i came
back and i read the news and i realized
that the united states is in an
apparently an irreversible state of
decline
that seems to be all the news that is
fit to prince and the great indicator of
this
was the situation that has now arisen
over the removal of the robert e lee
statue in virginia now here's the thing
i totally understand why people would
want the robert e lee statute removed in
richmond virginia i do i get it i
understand if you're a black american
and you look at a statue of robert ely
who presided over the army of the
confederacy which was an army that was
in favor of the remaining the the
continuation of slavery you look at that
statue and you say why exactly are
people paying homage to this man why
exactly would we do that isn't that a
vestige of american racism i get it i do
i also understand the people who are
descended from southerners who fought in
the civil war who look at lee and what
they see was a man who presided over the
the civil war yes but also presided over
reconstruction to the extent that he
didn't continue the guerrilla war right
this is a major issue at the time is
whether robert e lee was actually going
to continue to foment the civil war
after his surrender at appomattox and he
pledged that he would not do so and he
would use all of his efforts to bring
the country back together
there was a feeling in this out that he
was sort of the the romantic figure of
gentlemanliness some of that image has
been obviously tarnished by historians
who have now come forth with new details
about his life
but lee was a very human figure in a lot
of variegated forms and what that means
that people view him in different ways
so i totally understand the argument to
remove
robert e lee's statute i get it
i think that there are people who make
the argument that robert e lee statue
should come down for the same reason
that george washington or abraham
lincoln statue should come down that's
idiotic
and that is a different argument and
herein lies the problem and the problem
is not the pure removal of the robert e
lee statue although my view of this
generally is with conolisa rice's view
of this which is that statues generally
ought to remain up because they remind
us of a past when people were in fact
held in high esteem despite having
really really bad views and fighting for
really bad things and so that provides
you a jumping off point for discussion
of these issues what was going on in
america in 1858 right why did people
think in 1890 it was worthwhile to build
this statue of robert e lee's gigantic
21-foot statue of robert e lee right all
of those things are good for the
discussion of the american body politic
in american history it's kind of funny
that in a time when we are told that we
have to review american history and we
have to rethink american history there's
a simultaneous attempt to remove all the
iconography of the past in order that we
never have to discuss it ever again
right that's that's kind of bizarre
so my view is that the statue should
remain and we should discuss the statue
in all of its complexity and all of its
nuance
okay however
that's really not my issue here my issue
is what we replace things with what we
replace american history with what we
replaced that discussion with and what
we have decided to replace the
discussion of american history with what
we've decided to replace our own history
with
is a
perverse simplified wokeness that does
spell the end of america in pretty much
all of its forms not the getting rid of
the robert e lee statue per se but what
we are replacing it with and what i mean
here is that there was a time capsule
that was buried under the robert e lee
statue in the base of the statue we are
now replacing it okay this is the part
that's kind of astonishing and also
the imagery that was associated with the
removal of the robert lee statue right
if you are going to remove the
iconography of the past it should be
done
in a sort of i would say solemn fashion
it should be done very seriously
instead the robert e lee statue was
removed to the wild celebration of a
crowd below as though they were toppling
a statue of saddam hussein or something
robert e lee did not preside over the
country nor did he ever preside over the
country per se right he was the general
of the confederacy the confederacy was
defeated between 1861 and 1865
and uh you saw one of the people who was
taking this thing down we've been tasked
with taking this down putting up the
black lives matter fist as this was
taken down now you can say that maybe
the statue should be taken down but
replacing it with the ideology of black
lives matter which is that america is
invariably racist not only conflicts
with the actual imagery
which is
a black man taking down a statue of a
confederate general which does not be
speak the white supremacy of the united
states in 2021 but also black lives
matter is
is pushed and and based on a lie the lie
that black americans are
immutably
stricken by the american systems of
power that it's the same sort of
rationale as critical race theory black
lives matter and if you're a black
person in america you live with the boot
of america on your throat all day long
that obviously is not true i mean we're
literally taking down statues right now
right that offend people
but that sort of imagery is telling
what's even more telling is again the
time capsule so the time capsule to me
is the story not even the removal of the
statue the statue is a story but a much
bigger story and a more indicative story
is this time capsule removal because
they removed the time capsule
right which is generally you put
vestiges of what you think are the most
important objects of the day and you
bury them
and then in a hundred years the cool
thing about a time capsule is you open
it up and you have all the artifacts
from 120 years ago 130 years ago and you
can see what was important to people at
the time
what we replaced the objects in the time
capsule with underneath the robert e lee
statue says everything about this future
archaeologists are going to have zero
problems whatsoever understanding the
decline in fall of the united states
they're going to look at this time
capsule and they're going to go up well
that was not a toughy that was not
difficult it's not going to be edward
gibbon writing a millennium later trying
to figure out exactly why rome declined
and fell and trying to suss out all of
the various rationales
it it is not going to be trying to
discern the complexity of the fall of
the british empire it's gonna be like oh
yeah this time capsule kind of tells the
story like this this little box right
here i'll explain in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
big tech big government one of the
things that they have in common is they
want to monitor you at pretty much all
times and very often they want to use
the data that they monitor against you
let's say you're a proud gun owner and
you want to talk on social media about
the right to bear arms well chances are
your post will be flagged by a content
moderator you might end up on some kind
of government watch list to fight back
against having your voice censored by
both big tech and big government i
recommend expressvpn see the problem
with big tech is not only do they
attempt to censor you but they also
track what you do online what you're
searching for the videos you watch
everything you click
they can match your activity to your
true identity using your device's unique
ip address when i use expressvpn they
can't see my ip address at all my
identity is anonymized by a secure vpn
server plus expressvpn encrypts 100 of
my internet data for protection from
hackers and eavesdroppers expressvpn is
by far the best vpn i've tried there's a
reason that it is number one rated by
cnet tech radar countless other tech
publications go check them out right now
it's super easy right you just download
it with one click another click you are
now protected with expressvpn stop
letting big tech and big government
censor and track you defend your rights
protect yourself at
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com slash ben to get
three months for free visit
expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so here is
the actual story behind the story
so they got rid of the robert e lee
statue
and then they took away
the artifacts that were inside this time
capsule that had been placed in the
pedestal of the monument on october 27
1887.
they said that the
objects in the old capsule were believed
to have ties to the confederacy ralph
northam the governor who also apparently
had ties to the confederacy considering
he was either wearing blackface or a kkk
outfit in his medical yearbook he says
this monument and its time capsule
reflected virginia in 1890 and it's time
to remove both so our public spaces
better reflect who we are as a people in
2021. now here we go
what exactly was in the new time capsule
right what what what did they decide
that they were going to place inside the
new time capsule
this is supposed to remember signify
what america is all about what is in the
artifact list now
okay so here is what they put in there
they put in there a black lives matter
sticker
which is again signification of a
movement
that suggests that america is
irredeemably racist
they took down a robert e lee statue
because america's irredeemably racist
so you've got these stickers saying
america's irredeemably racist
they have writing a new history kente
cloth worn by the commissioners of the
congressionally chartered 400 years of
african american history commission and
ghanaian emissaries that participated in
the 400th commemoration of 1619.
all right so we have we have a kente
cloth in commemoration of the 1619
project which again is a
designation that america is rooted in
evil and can never be extricated from
that evil and all of its institutions
are shot through with that evil evil we
have a virginia is for lovers pride pin
and sticker
which is great so we have a pride pin
signifying our our love and and
celebration of alternative sexual
proclivities and behaviors
not not of the family no you not like
the signification of the family but like
the pride pen
we have also
the virginia ratify era equal rights
amendment sash and the equal rights
amendment 2020 pins
so that's very important right so we
have an equal rights amendment sash and
pins for a constitutional amendment that
is not actually adopted and that
suggests that there are no differences
between men and women in law
we have a first lady face mask submitted
by first lady pamela northam
so first so it's her own face mask that
goes in the time capsule it's important
future generations know that we were
insane and that we face masked
presumably until the end of the american
republic we have photos and flyers from
stop asian hate protests in may 2021 in
the virginia time capsule
now so far have you heard anything that
celebrates america like a single thing
in this time capsule that says that
america is good or that our fundamental
institutions are good
nope
zero things
none
the only thing that really has to do
with the institutions of virginia per se
is a photo of the virginia state police
at 14th street and
an f street northwest in washington
helping washington metro police
department patrol the city for unrest
after the insurrection at the u.s
capitol on january 6th that's we have a
commemoration of january 6th
which is really important so people
understand that the real threats of the
united states which bunch of drugs who
ran into the capitol building
we have an expired vial of the covet 19
pfizer vaccine and the cdc vaccination
record card
so if you think that america
has always been rooted in a creed that
america has a civic religion and
typically that civic religion is
embodied by the declaration of
independence say the american flag apple
pie motherhood all of that
we've now replaced this with the pride
flag pin a kente claw for 1619.
the the pseudo-pagan
worship
of
scientific materialism via a covet 19
vaccine vial and a face mask for the
first lady
yeah i really don't think that the
future is going to have a very tough
time figuring out exactly
why um why america fell i feel like this
one's going to be real easy for us
and here's the thing
as america collapses within and america
collapses without
the story is that we are basically just
going to eat ourselves to death we're
now the plot of wall-e right the best
hope for the united states according to
the democrats and according to joe biden
is that as we rip ourselves apart as we
lose all centralizing principle as we
collapse on the foreign front as we do
all of those things at the very least
what we can do is park our asses in a
recliner and just eat
a bunch of fatty foods until we die
that's it and the government will pay
for all of that unless you're
unvaccinated in which case die on your
own but otherwise the government will
pay for all of these things we'll get to
all of this in just one second because
the polarization continues to pace what
we're watching is a america come apart
at the seams
an intolerant left that refuses to
acknowledge that there are other people
in the united states who still
want to live by the promises of the
declaration of independence and the
constitution of the united states and
instead want us to plant a racial
tribalism and a and a
sort of sexual profligacy
that is uh
unmoored from reality growth or decency
they want to do all of these things and
and then they want to pay you to
basically ignore it
we'll get to more of this in a second i
know it's a depressing message coming
back from the jewish new year but i call
them like i see them we'll get some more
of this in just one second first let's
talk about something great you can do
for your family let's talk about legacy
box legacy box is your chance to have
aging tapes films and photos digitally
preserved so the essential people and
moments from your family's history can
be revisited and shared for generations
this week legacy box is offering 50 off
at legacybox.com shapiro so you can turn
a lifetime of memories into a highlight
reel your family history deserves to be
highlighted and shared so we've used
legacy box ourselves i went over my
parents house
a bunch of old film reels they had a
bunch of old pictures they had a bunch
of stuff like vhs tapes that were just
falling apart and we stuffed them in a
box sent them to legacy box
legacy box monitored them the whole time
so we knew where they were in the
process and then they sent back these
digitally preserved copies and the
originals and my parents are able to
access them they gave us copies of all
of them really really cool stuff legacy
boxes a simple way to keep loved ones
close
they've helped over one million families
restore and protect their most cherished
memories visit legacybox.com
shapiro to take advantage of this
limited time offer for 50 off honor the
moments that have shaped your family i
think this stuff is super duper
important take advantage of this
exclusive offer today and then use their
kit whenever you are ready that's
legacybox.com shapiro to say 50 right
now legacybox.com
shapiro okay so it is not merely that
the sort of
virginia time capsule is a time capsule
of america is that the people who are
putting together things like the
virginia time capsule believe that this
is what america should look like
uniformly there is no tolerance for
other points of view this doesn't come
courtesy of me this comes courtesy of
thomas edsel who is certainly no
conservative writing for the new york
times he has a piece today that is quite
fascinating he says a highly charged
ideological transition reflecting a
massive four decade long shift in
political values and attitudes among
more educated people a shift from
concern with traditional materialist
issues like redistribution to a concern
for public goods like the environment
and diversity is a driving force in the
battle between left and right according
to richard florida an urbanologist at
the university of toronto this
ideological transition has been
accompanied by the concentration of
liberal elites and urban centers florida
continued in an email brought on by the
dramatic shift to a knowledge economy
which expresses itself on the left as
wokeness and on the right as populism i
worry that the middle is dropping out of
american politics this is not just an
economic or cultural or political
phenomenon it is inextricably geographic
or spatial as different groups pack and
cluster into different types of
community
recent decades have witnessed what
dennis chung political scientist at
university of southern california
describes in an email as quote a
demographic realignment of political
tolerance in the us that first became
evident in the late 1980s and early
1990s
before that chong pointed out that
college-educated and younger generations
were among the most tolerant groups in
the society of all forms of social and
political non-conformity since the 1990s
these groups have become significantly
less tolerant of quote-unquote hate
speech pertaining to race gender and
social identities
chung argued the expansion of equal
rights for racial and ethnic minorities
women lgbtq and other groups that have
suffered discrimination has caused a
re-evaluation of the harms of slurs and
other derogatory expressions in
professional and social life
the result chong writes in a striking
reversal liberals are now consistently
less tolerant than conservatives of a
wide range of controversial speech about
racial gender and religious identities
so there's been a shift from the program
of the left being about materialist
redistribution right we're just going to
take some money from here we're going to
put it over here
toward
an attempt to cram down a particular
woke point of view you might call it an
authoritarian moment
yes that is indeed a self-referential
mention of my book title
because that is what we are experiencing
we're experiencing an authoritarian
moment a replacement ideology
the traditional american ideology is
being replaced wholesale with an
ideology that divides us along racial
and religious and tribal and sexual
orientation lines and then demands that
everybody who disagrees with you shut
the hell
up and this is being crammed down at
every level of our society
it's part of the dissolution of american
influence it's part of the dissolution
of american principles what exactly
unifies us and it's being crammed down
and again every institutional level in
our society so chris ruffo who's been
doing excellent work over at manhattan
institute
he uncovered an indoctrination session
over at google
according to rufo google has launched an
anti-racism initiative claiming that
america is a system of white supremacy
and that all americans are raised to be
racist including me
like me personally i'm depicted in the
layer of the white supremacy pyramid
culminating in genocide
so they had an allyship learning session
in a model in a module called allyship
in action google trained employees to
deconstruct their racial and sexual
identities and then rank themselves in a
hierarchy of power and privilege and
manage their reactions through crying
and accessing their happy place
again this is all being taught at google
the single most powerful company on
planet earth and nearly everybody gets
their information through google or one
of its associated companies like youtube
in a video guest lecturer ibram kendi
claimed all americans including children
as young as three months old are racist
he said to be raised in the united
states is to be raised as racist and to
be raised to be racist is to be raised
to be almost addicted to racist ideas
and says candy
the heartbeat of racism is denial and
the sound of that denial is i'm not
racist we now have a pure kafka trap in
which if you say i'm not racist this
means that you are a hundred percent
definitely racist if you say you're
racist also you're racist because you
just admitted you're racist
also nicole hannah jones admitted in a
lecture to google that she created the
6019 project to verify her lifelong
theory that everything in the modern day
united states can be traced back to
slavery quote if you name anything in
america i can relate it back to slavery
she says if you're white in this country
or the beneficiary of a 350-year system
of white supremacy how about if you're a
tenured professor without any teaching
experience or any apparently apparent
skill set
celebrated and paid money to do what you
do are you a beneficiary of the 350-year
system of white supremacy also nicole
hannah jones
okay and then they came up with a
graphic titled the white supremacy
pyramid
again this is the tolerant left
and this is the cultural left that has
decided that again
all of america's founding ideals and
even nuanced parts of american history
are replaced with a simple narrative in
which america is just bad
and the only things that are good are
people who stand up to that evil system
okay so they have the white supremacy
pyramid
busting the myth of white genocide in
south africa i don't know what this has
to do with white genocide in south
africa but they say the white supremacy
pyramid at the bottom is indifference
okay there are two sides again this is
being taught to all of your bettors at
google the people who control the flow
of information indifference there are
two sides to every story eight political
beliefs avoiding confrontation politics
don't affect me so if you just beg out
of a question if you just say listen i'm
really not involved in this or i don't
follow it closely or i don't know enough
that's not okay
minimization okay and then there's a
picture of me right i'm on the bottom of
the white supremacy pyramid that leads
to mass murder there's a picture of
yours truly now as we all know if
there's one person that the white
supremacist absolutely adores me they
just love me which is why they routinely
send me death threats why the fbi had to
arrest the white supremacist two years
ago for threatening my family yeah the
white
people me they're
they they spend all day just singing my
praises
okay that is sarcasm for those in the
media who apparently are incapable of
understanding human expression okay so i
am engaged according to the white
supremacy pyramid in minimization the
white savior complex
i'm confused what it seems to me that
that is liberals who are involved in the
white savior complex they believe that
they are the only ones with the moral
wherewithal to fix the evil systems of
the united states minimization not all
white people
so um how is it minimization to say not
all white people but
it is
somehow not minimization to say not all
black people not all white people and
not all black people that's being more
specific specificity is good not
believing people of color's experiences
well my general rule is that i believe
your emotional state but that does not
mean that your emotional state is always
justified
right jesse smalley was not justified
also
i can i can believe that you
misinterpreted something denial of white
privilege
again hard to see how the heroin addict
living in
a rust belt town in ohio is a is a
beneficiary of white privilege post
racism so if you say that we should move
beyond racism that's minimization and
intentions are greater than impact okay
so i say when i say that in order to be
racist you actually have to do a racist
thing meaning that there has to be like
actual racist content to the thing
you're doing
their argument is that if there is any
just a disparate impact
based on race of any policy this is
minimization that eventually leads to
mass murder then you get to veiled
racism which is like victim blaming and
racist jokes are eurocentric curriculum
if you teach shakespeare you teach
chaucer all of this is eurocentric
discriminate racist icons which i assume
would mean like presumably
who racist icons would be like
george washington maybe for these folks
discrimination calls for violence
violence and then finally mass murder
right this is the um this is the notion
here
and um and the cops of course are
included in um lynching hate crimes and
police brutality all the same all the
same
so uh that's that is what your bettors
are teaching people over at google
right and this is
spread across the corporate sector
this is all about the collapse of the
united states at home the militarization
of our institutions of power against at
least half of the population and
probably a lot more we'll get some more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that if you've been
listening to the show for a while you
know i love my helix sleep mattress it
is the only thing that allows me to
sleep since my kids simply won't but now
the folks at helix they've gone further
than this they've created a fantastic
new couch it's called the all form this
new company it's called all form they're
making premium customizable sofas and
shares shipped directly to your door so
what makes an all form sofa really cool
well for starters
it's the easiest way you can customize
the sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain scratch resistant the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
and shape make sure it's perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you want
your all form sofa to grow and change
with you when you move all form sofas
are delivered directly to your door in
the past you needed like somebody who
actually knew how to put together a
couch to do it for you not so with all
form it's very easy to do i've done it
myself i have it all formed so far i
picked out the three seat sofa with
chase in the sand color with espresso
legs it is fantastic it is durable my
kids can beat the hell out of it it
still looks fantastic right now all form
is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
ben again that's all form dot com pen
have a forever warranty literally for
all time and you have at least three
months to figure out if you want to keep
it you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it so you got no risk it's
a fantastic sofa i guarantee it all for
them offering 20 off all orders right
now at allform.com
go check them out right now okay so
this obviously
has crossed all sorts uh this wokeness
the intolerant left which is destroying
our culture from within and destroying
any level of comedy and any level of
unity from within this is infused to all
of our institutions all of our major
institutions which is why you saw over
the weekend warby parker which is some
sort of eyeglasses story i'll admit to
uh not knowing them particularly well
apparently warby parker
decided that they were angry
that their ads cropped up
on
our website daily wire
so
here's the thing ads on our site are
largely automated it is not as though
warby parker was like we definitely need
to appear on daily wire but even if they
had who cares like that's good i don't
care if warby parker appears on the
on the abc news or nbc news or or hell
daily coast website i don't care it
makes no difference to me but it
apparently makes a huge difference to
people on the left got very very angry
at warby parker for one of their ads
automatically cropping up on the daily
wire page
and warby parker then decided to
make a statement that they were not
going to allow their ads to appear on
our page ever ever again
so
here's the thing
all of you guys you know all of my fans
feel free to never go to warby parker
again
really they just lost a lot more
customers by me saying that than they
did by taking the ad by leaving the ad
on the site if they left the ad on the
site i wouldn't be on the air right now
telling you not to shop at warby parker
but don't bother because obviously their
wokeness takes priority over their
interest in reaching you the consumers
who include by the way many people who
don't agree with me on politics
as kevin williams in a national review
puts it he says
all of these people you know who listen
to my show they do buy reasonably priced
eyewear
they've bought eyewear at the warby
parker store at north park center in
dallas at the warby parker boutique in
the woodlands in addison at west bend in
fort worth at legacy point in plano
warby parker's co-ceo neil blumenthal
rejoices in the greenwich village
address in which he pays a multi-million
dollar home decorated with jeff kuhn's
paintings but pays but a good chunk of
his customer base lives elsewh elsewhere
so do his employees so do a lot of his
potential investors because the company
is currently planning an ipo so i look
forward to none of the people who listen
to my show buying their stock
or short selling that would be just
terrible if warby parker's stock were to
tank over this i'd feel so so bad but
the point is this these corporations
have decided they're going to mirror the
woke priorities of a radical left that
is seeking to destroy any level of
common cause in the united states which
is why lyft is now proudly coming out
and saying that they're going to pay the
legal bills for any drivers who get sued
under the new texas abortion law now
maybe they have to do that legally
because they don't want people
who work for lyft quitting their job out
of fear of legal liability
but that's not all they said they didn't
just say listen we want to protect all
of our drivers from legal liability no
matter where they're transporting people
because listen we're just a
transportation company and so we're
going to contribute to their defense
instead the lyft general counsel came
out and said every single company should
follow our lead and actually
fund the abortion process like this is
we're doing an active good abortion is
an active good these are your major
corporations here's the lift general
counsel
you know nicole i wish i knew um i i
think abortion has been historically
considered a third rail issue
one that businesses don't take a stand
on i i hope that that changes i hope
that this is the moment that that
changes
um i'm very proud to work at lyft where
we bring our values to the forefront and
i'm very proud to have two male
co-founders john and logan
who
actually this idea
originated with logan our ceo and of
course i was very happy to stand in
support of it and i'm happy to be
speaking with you now
many women and many men nearly everybody
knows a loved one
maybe themselves a partner who has had
an abortion and this is a women's rights
a women's health issue so this should be
an issue that every company is willing
to speak out on
america's corporations are militarized
against traditional americans and their
world views and their values right from
google to lyft
and not just that our university system
obviously so over the weekend peter
bogosian who is this professor over at
portland state university
he quit portland state university
because he said it's just become
unlivable here you guys have made it
like freedom of inquiry is just not a
thing here
he says i eventually became convinced
corrupted bodies of scholarship were
responsible for justifying radical
departures from the traditional role of
liberal arts schools in basic civility
on campus and so he engaged in what was
called the so-called squared hoax right
where he he submitted a bunch of fake
papers to a bunch of academic journals
to demonstrate how stupid the academic
journals are one of them in 2017 was an
intentionally garbled peer-reviewed
paper that took aim at the new orthodoxy
it's titled what its title was quote the
conceptual penis as a social construct
it was published in cogent social
science sciences which is a journal it
argued penises were the product of the
human mind and responsible for climate
change
okay this resulted in such blowback from
portland state university that he ended
up having to quit
administrators and faculty were so
angered by the papers as peter bogosian
they published an anonymous piece in the
student paper and portland state filed
formal charges against me they accused
him of research misconduct based on the
absurd premise the journal editors who
accepted our intentionally deranged
articles were human subjects
right as though he was experimenting on
them with a drug of some sort
meanwhile ideological intolerance
continued to grow up portland state in
march a tenured profession professor
disrupted a public conversation i was
holding with author christina hofsomers
an evolutionary biologist brett
weinstein and heather heing in june 2018
someone triggered the fire alarm during
my conversation with popular cultural
critic carl benjamin in october 2018 an
activist pulled the speaker wires to
interrupt a panel with former google
engineer james deboer no one was
punished or disciplined
he said this is about the kind of
institutions we want and the kind of
values we choose every idea that has
advanced human freedom has always
without fail been initially condemned as
individuals we often seem incapable of
remembering this lesson that's exactly
what our institutions are for to remind
us the freedom to question is our
fundamental right portland state
university has failed in fulfilling this
duty this of course is exactly right
and it's not just those institutions
it's our scientific institutions that
are failing us
over the weekend
a series of medical journals 200 of them
decided to issue a statement about
climate change medical journals i don't
know what your podiatrist knows about
climate change hell i don't know what
your podiatrist your podiatrist knows
about gastroenterology
but apparently we are supposed to
believe that if you have an md after
your name you're suddenly an expert in
climatology
okay because all of our institutions
have been corrupted by woke group thing
by left-wing groupthink which is taking
all of the commonalities that we have
and tearing them apart from science to
higher learning to free speech
to even the notion of a color-blind
meritocracy all of those things are
being destroyed
piece by piece in the united states
and of course we are supposed to ignore
it
all of this culminates by the way in
bully tactics that are given the full
go-ahead by the media
most obvious case in point over the
course of the last couple of days is
this video that i discovered when i came
online of my friend larry elder who's
running for governor of california and
who happens to be a black man walking
through a crowd and a woke
awoke person
wearing a gorilla mask throwing an egg
at him
but this woman is woke and white so this
means that she's an anti-racist activist
and larry is conservative in black which
means of course that he's a white
supremacist the headline from the media
is more like anti-racist activist throws
egg at evil white supremacist but here's
the actual video of a black man having
an egg thrown at him by a woman wearing
a gorilla mask which is apparently
totally fine because again morality is
beside the point
there's larry walking down the street
with the security and there is a white
woman with pink hair and a gorilla mask
and then hitting a security guard
so
all of this is fine all of this is good
by the way imagine if the situation
reversed an old white tea party you're
throwing an egg at a black congress
person from the democratic party and you
can imagine what the response would be
about the systemic racism of america
in just one second we'll get to the
collapse of america abroad because the
collapse of america at home is perfectly
clear
first let's talk for a second about the
earbuds that you are using so you need
to chill out for a second you need to
just take a breath but for me that means
popping a great set of earbuds in my
ears and then listening to a book on
tape or listening to a podcast or
listening to some nice music a raycons
can make all of that happen to you
when the world gets too loud something i
love is to create my own soundtrack
popping in my recon wireless earbuds
sometimes you need some upbeat music to
pump you up before you see people or to
stay calm with some guided meditation
let me tell you right now raycon's are
the best way to listen they come with a
bunch of gel tips for your comfort
unlike some other brands they don't
stick out of your ears recons have a 32
hour battery life you can listen to what
you want when you want it for a really
long time they start at half the price
of other premium audio brands they sound
just as good and raycon's come with a
45-day happiness guarantee so you really
can't lose give them a try you'll see
what i mean create your own soundtrack
with raycon today right now my listeners
can get 15 off their raycon order at
slash byracon.com that's b u y r a y c o
n dot com slash ben to say fifteen
percent on ray cons by raycon dot com
slash ben go check them out right now
buy raycon dot com slash ben to learn
more alrighty so
as we collapse here at home as our
values are undermined as we replace
our values with time capsules of
wokeness it is a natural progression
that as a country declines from within
it declines abroad and obviously what's
been happening in afghanistan is the
greatest case in point the taliban has
now unveiled its brand new afghan
government and i am amused to see that
the media are deeply upset that the new
taliban government includes zero women
and zero trans people it's very very
upsetting they don't care that it's a
terrorist state but the fact that there
are no women who work with the taliban
is very upsetting to them if they had a
woman on there that's a brand new
taliban same old principles but there's
a person who is a woman
i mean frankly what the taliban should
just do is say
you know
muhammad here is a woman and the left
would have nothing to say
because obviously a man can be a woman
and then that would solve all of their
problems they gave senior post to the
leader of haqqani network which of
course is an al-qaeda link group
he's the minister of the interior so
he's going to handle all interior
security is a terrorist associated with
al qaeda
so things are going just beautifully
according to the wall street journal in
an appointment that would complicate any
recognition of the new government by
western nations sarah houdina haqqani
designated a global terrorist by
washington because of close links
between al qaeda and the haqqani network
he heads was named minister of the
interior with oversight of afghanistan's
police and internal security the fbi is
currently offering a reward of up to
five million dollars for information
leading to his arrest okay i have some
information on where he is he's in the
government building right now he's like
the seat of government he's minister of
the interior in afghanistan am i am i up
for the five million now fbi
well the taliban supreme leader
haibatullah
akum zada retains overall oversight of
the state affairs the new prime minister
is mala hasan akun who served as foreign
minister in the old islamic emirate
which harvard which harbored osama bin
laden and was ousted by from power in
2001.
akunzada said quote our previous 20
years of struggle in jihad had two major
goals first to end foreign occupation
and aggression and liberate the country
and secondly to establish a complete
independent stable and central islamic
system in the country
based on this principle in the future
all matters of governance and life in
afghanistan will be regulated by the
laws of the holy sharia
what does that look like well it looks
like the taliban being living hell out
of people
so that's
great according to the new york times
tensions flared with neighboring
pakistan afghanistan's long-standing
humanitarian crisis has deepened and the
militants brutal crackdown on descent
threatens to further erode public trust
the taliban who witnesses say crushed
several small protests around the
country on wednesday have been rounding
up scores of demonstrators and
subjecting them to abuse in overcrowded
jails according to journalists who were
present the depression followed a
taliban announcement tuesday protests
would not be allowed without government
approval which is the best kind of
protest the best kind of protest is the
one where the government says okay to
the protest
several afghan journalists said they've
been arrested and beaten in custody they
didn't just say it they took pictures of
what it looked like after they'd been
beaten in custody
so um
i noticed that um we heard constant
yammering during the trump
administration about the terrible fate
of american journalists like jim acosta
sitting in an air-conditioned radio
studio reading his brand new book
uh and how brave they were i'm not i'm
noticing a significant lack
of concern by these very same people
over the treatment of journalists in
afghanistan that's that's totally fine
that they are having the absolute
hellbeat out of them
apparently nemat a videographer
for atiyat iras a local newspaper said
that he and his colleagues had just
arrived in the street where several
dozen women were gathered with placards
and a loudspeaker when taliban militants
from the police station seized his
camera and arrested him
he said they took me into a room tied my
hands with a scarf and started beating
me with a cable
also taliban fighters uh started beating
women who arrived at a university the
other day that video was available
online as well
there are women arriving in university
and uh
there they are just getting uh beaten
with sticks by the taliban it's
different taliban guys more moderate our
friends now our friends now
so peter ducey had the temerity to ask
this to gensake said um i noticed i i
might have noticed that um there are
more people in the afghan government who
are
recognized global terrorists than our
women do you have anything to say about
that gensake no no of course not
there are now more terrorists wanted by
the fbi and the new afghan government
than there are
women does the president think that is a
foreign policy success
well first of all no one in this
administration not the president nor
anyone on the national security team
would suggest that the taliban are
respected and valued members of the
global community
um
yeah now that's going to do it we need
to we need you know they're gonna have
to earn their way into the global
community i noticed that china is about
to recognize them it turns out that you
just lost a war to them for no reason
literally no reason just to placate your
80 year old daughtering senile boss so
really well done everybody really well
done by the way saki did not rule out
recognizing the government and she's
asked specifically about recognizing the
government she's like man maybe
waiting for them to do
they just form their government but are
you waiting for something
uh some waiting for what you're saying
that we're not gonna rush to recognition
that means that there could be
recognition
as we've said many times the
international community is watching the
united states is watching it's whether
they let people uh depart the country
who want to depart whether they treat
women across the country as they have
committed to treat them and how they
behave and operate and therefore we're
not moving toward recognition
uh yeah i've noticed that they're not
doing any of those things i've noticed i
love tony blinken down playing this the
secretary of state uh he was asked about
the taliban regime he's like well you
know their their track records are
challenging
uh challenging is is a word for like you
have a test tomorrow in biology and you
didn't study until the last minute
that's challenging
not challenging is
what to do about the fact that you just
handed over an entire country to
terrorists
second
with regard to the composition of this
government or or interim government
i noted
the fact that
it certainly does not meet the test of
inclusivity
and it includes wow
people who um
have uh very challenging track records
harsh words there taliban failing the
test of inclusivity who could have i
mean honestly i'm not sure why he says
that it's the most diverse government
i've ever seen we've been told that
diversity is not a matter of reflecting
the population generally diversity is
just a matter of you're not white so
i've noticed that there are no white
people who are members of the taliban
government and they're all muslim
actually so that's a by american
standard it's a very diverse government
actually is the way that this works but
uh it is an absurdity piled on top of
absurdity and uh on top of that
obviously there's still americans who
are trapped in afghanistan and the biden
administration made that happen we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let us talk about the fact there's no
reason to go to an auto parts store like
pretty much ever especially when you can
just use rockauto.com rockauto.com is so
much easier than walking into the store
waiting in line you get to the front of
the line they ask a bunch of specific
questions about your car and then like
yeah bro we don't have the part and then
they order it online and three weeks
later you have to come back in and then
they up charge you or you could just do
it online yourself rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
exact parts the rockauto.com catalog is
unique it's remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
you've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com go check them out right now
rockauto.com see all the parts available
for your car truck and write shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you all right
we'll get to more on this in a second
the surrender of afghanistan collapse at
home collapse abroad don't worry they'll
try to bribe you after controlling you
first in remembrance of the men and
women who lost their lives 20 years ago
and the worst terror attack committed on
american soil i sat down with one of the
people who shouldered much of the
political burden placed on the bush
administration in the aftermath on last
sunday's episode of the sunday special
i was joined by former secretary of
state conolisa rice she was an excellent
and moving guest it's available right
now it's informative it's vital
listening if you haven't had the chance
check it out right now obviously one of
the most brilliant women in the history
of american politics also a person with
a front row view of what exactly was
going on on september 11th in
afghanistan in iraq she had a lot to say
go stream it right now at dailywire.com
on the daily wire apple tv or roku app
or on my youtube channel ben shapiro
dailywire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday special
episodes don't miss out join daily wire
today
also if you like daily wire backstage i
have some excellent news for you this
october not only will we be live and on
stage at the famous ryman auditorium in
nashville we're also giving one lucky
member a chance to win two vip tickets
to get front row seats not just that the
winner will receive a fifteen hundred
dollar gift card to cover travel
expenses a meet and greet with the
backstage hosts and more tickets for the
ramen chart are already sold out so this
is your one chance to get in on the
action it is your last chance enter when
you go to dailywire.com subscribe join
one of our membership plans with the
code backstage for 25 percent off your
membership
if you're already a member you'll be
automatically entered so get ready
because you might just be on your way to
nashville to meet and hang out with me
jeremy boring michael knowles matt walsh
andrew clavin and candace owens next
month you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile if you thought that
afghanistan well you know we're just
forgetting about it no big deal well um
no one can get out so they're a bunch of
americans who are still stuck there
according to the wall street journal
efforts to get 100 stranded americans
and thousands of vulnerable afghans out
of afghanistan founded on wednesday as
the taliban imposed more restrictions on
flights out of the country according to
people involved in the rescue efforts
the taliban have refused to allow any
commercial flights out of afghanistan
since the us military withdrawal
since then private efforts to fly people
out of afghanistan have hit roadblock
after roadblock u.s negotiations with
the taliban have failed to clear the way
salma khalilzad america's special envoy
on afghanistan peace talks has been
sending urgent requests to the taliban
to allow americans and afghans to leave
said one state department official but
the efforts have produced no
breakthrough okay so the taliban are
just holding them hostage but says the
administration they're not being held
hostage just as remember they were not
stranded now they're not being held
hostage it's just that the taliban are
not letting them leave
right which is like saying
that a person who has been kidnapped is
not kidnapped it's just that the
kidnapper refuses to allow them to leave
the house and has chained them in the
basement other than that they're totally
free to leave here's tony blinken making
that absurd contention
as of now
the taliban are not permitting the
charter flights to depart
they claim that some of the passengers
do not have the required documentation
while there are limits to what we can do
without personnel on the ground without
an airport with normal security
procedures in place
we are working to do everything in our
power to support those flights
and to get them off the ground
that's what we've done that's what we
will continue to do
we're going to jabber at the taliban
it's worked so far it's working just
fabulously meanwhile jen's hockey was
asked uh you know i noticed that there's
nobody on the ground actually
negotiating with the taliban to get
these people out or provide them aid or
anything there's no one on the ground at
all whose fault is that
and gensake has no answer because
obviously it's this administration's
fault so instead she's just like we're
not going to discuss blame
us blame
no no we're not going to do that
following up on these charter flights
that the taliban is holding up in
afghanistan the secretary of state said
there are limits to what we can do
without personnel on the ground yeah you
just said we are not on the ground
you're right whose fault is that
i don't think this is about fault here
i'm convinced i think what people want
to understand is what we're doing to
help address it
it's not about fault guys it's not about
fault that's not at all
okay so what we have here is in america
in collapse at home in terms of values
of an america that is consequently in
collapse abroad and we can't even bring
our citizens home in the face of eighth
century barbarians that we gave tens of
billions of dollars of american weaponry
to
and then so what is the offer here so
what is the offer seriously by the
democrats for keeping the country
together so i get the offer from some
people which is let's restore the basic
idea of the american bargain right
that's my idea my idea is we go back to
the declaration of independence we look
at its founding principles we look at
the basic ideas that brought america
together as a country and then were
perfected in their performance over the
course of two centuries and we go back
to that right we actually build on the
creed again we try to reinstill social
institutions with some value we try to
to
find communities in which we treat each
other decently right these would be my
preferred solutions but
democrats have a different preferred
solution their preferred solution is top
down control because they're not
opposing the wokes right they don't
oppose the social agenda they forward
the social agenda and foment the social
agenda of the radical left and tearing
apart the creedal american nation in
order
to replace it with a big gut like the
idea here is if you can tear down all
the systems what you will replace it
with is a command and control economy
complete with command and control of how
people raise their children
in the end the promise is utter control
right you are going to basically be
hooked up to the government iv and you
won't have to move you don't have to do
anything
you're gonna have to be a parent you're
gonna be a worker you won't have to be a
community member you won't have to do
anything the government is going to take
care of you and protect you from all bad
things in the world so long as you do
everything the government tells you to
do
this is the subtle promise behind what
the government is constantly telling us
about their vaccine policies is the
subtle promise behind what joe not so
subtle promise behind what joe biden
says about economics the idea is we
traded away american greatness the
greatness of our original ideals
we traded away the declaration of
independence and the constitution of the
united states in american history and
our power abroad we traded away all of
those things for a promise that the
government will keep us fat and happy
until we die that is the promise that
the democrats are making to us and you
can see it reflected in two particular
ways of late one is in coveted policy
and the other is in economic policy so
let's talk about coveted policy for a
second so
as i have been saying
in a normal world where the government's
job was not to protect you from every
ill of life we would now be at the end
of the pandemic because the government
has now done all it can do it has funded
the development of a near miraculous
vaccine that radically lowers the
hospitalization and death rates from
covid how successful are these vaccines
okay so you've been hearing all the
propaganda about breakthrough infections
and how you're going to die from it from
both right and left right from anti-vax
people but also from the people who are
in favor of top-down government control
and forever masking and never go back to
work and all of this crap
how effective are these vaccines i'm the
biggest vaccine advocate i believe on
either right or left why because they're
damned effective they're unbelievably
effective here's how effective they are
according to the new york times
the rate of infection in unvaccinated
people is about five times the rate of
infection in vaccinated people
so every week
the average incidence of covet 19 among
vaccinated people per week right like
your chances of getting covered this
week if you are a if you are
if you are a vaccinated person
is about 64 per 100 000 people
64 per 100 000 people so boil that down
it's about six in ten thousand
right or one in 25
in two thousand one in one in fifteen
hundred sixteen hundred those are your
chances of getting a case of covid okay
not of being hospitalized or dying your
chances of being hospitalized
if you are if you are if you get a
breakthrough if you're vaccinated your
chance of being hospitalized if you're
vaccinated total
is one in 100 000 people
if you are currently vaccinated your
chance of going to the hospital is one
in 100
this now means
that for the vaccinated this pandemic is
over was over and has been over for a
very long time what it also means that
for the unvaccinated the pandemic is
over to the extent that it is no one
else's job to protect you from getting a
disease against which you can protect
yourself
anymore then it is somebody else's job
to strap a mattress to the front of
their car if you don't wear a seat belt
because god forbid you should get in a
car crash you might fly through your
windshield and we have to put a mattress
in front of our car to make sure that it
catches you that is no one's obligation
it is your job to wear your seatbelt it
is your job to get the vaccine or not to
get the vaccine now it's up to you right
that's what we would say in a free
country with an effective vaccine
instead what we've decided is to
cram down the idea that the government
can keep you safe from every single
thing that exists
and they have to look for a hook for
this right because it's killing the
economy democrats are still pursuing
lockdown policies democrats are still
pursuing universal masking they're still
suggesting that we need economic
stimulus so they need some sort of hook
for this so the hook they've come up for
this is that pediatric cases are spiking
right there there are a lot of cases
that are coming up of children who are
being diagnosed with covet now the
reason that more children are being
diagnosed with covet is not because tons
and tons and tons of kids are stacking
up in the icu that is not correct the
reason that there are more cases of cova
that are now being identified is because
most schools before you go back to
school require a covet test and a huge
number of asymptomatic or mildly
symptomatic covid positive tests are
coming back
according to the cdc the risk to
children from covid right the infection
fatality rate from coveted for children
remains the same now post delta as it
was pre-delta it is not more dangerous
to kids it is just more widespread among
kids
hey there's a difference between
dangerous and widespread
your chances of dying if you get covered
and you're under the age of 18 are
basically not basically precisely so far
as we are aware the same as they were
before the delta variant it's just that
there's a better chance that you're
going to get covered and have to undergo
that risk
but the media have decided to make this
in an area of absolute panic which by
the way is not the case in the uk where
they're not masking kids it is not the
case in anywhere in scandinavia it is
not the case
in spain is not the case in italy it is
not the case nearly
in a bunch of places in europe it is not
the case
but we got to panic everybody so
according to the new york post pediatric
coronavirus cases have spiked across the
nation as schools prepared to reopen
their doors for a new academic year
according to the american academy of
pediatrics pediatric covenant 19 cases
flew past 250 000 for the week ending
september 2nd
the washington post reported that more
than a quarter of all cases that week
were among kids and teens
almost 2 400 of those infections
required hospitalization
okay but the amount of hospitalization
required is generally pretty low the
number of kids who have died total in
the united states is about 400 over the
course of the entire pandemic
okay so
the the notion that we should be
panicking over children at this point is
also kind of crazy nonetheless los
angeles is now mandating that every
person 12 and up get a vaccine
la according to the new york times is
poised to become the first major school
district in the nation to mandate covet
vaccines for students 12 and older
attending class in person
students would need to receive their
first vaccine dose by november 21st and
their second dose by december 19th in
order to begin the next semester fully
inoculated those are 212 after those
dates will have 30 days after their
birthday to receive their first shot
students participating in
extracurriculars will need to receive
both shots by the end of october
now
here is the thing the risk to children
of this like if you're a parent
this is not something that um is
necessarily super clear-cut
particularly the second shot okay there
is a study it is now in pre-print okay
it's a study from tracy beth hogg
allison krug josh stevenson and josh
mandrella
and the study
is um of the
myocarditis symptoms
of kids between the ages of 12 and 17
who get the vaccine
so what they did is they analyzed the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
right which is sort of you know a system
that where you're reporting all of your
adverse events it is you can't always
tell whether this is driven
by the vaccine which is why the data is
kind of sketchy but it's what that's the
only data that we have because the
government refuses to do any of the
actual research it should be doing
so what they did is they went through
the search criteria for myocarditis
pericarditis and myo-opera carditas to
identify kids with evidence of cardiac
injury they included the word troponin
in the laboratory findings to see if uh
troponin rather was a required element
in laboratory findings they were trying
to narrow down cases in which parents
were complaining that their kids had a
heart related vaccine
symptom
what they found
is that the rates per million following
dose two among males were 162.2
and 94.0 for ages 12 to 15 and 16 to 17
that's per million rates among females
were 13 and 13.4 per million
for boys 12 to 15 without medical
comorbidities the rate of these cardiac
adverse events is 3.7 to 6.1 times
higher than their 120-day covet
hospitalization risk as of august 21st
and 2.6 to 4.3 fold higher at times of
high weekly hospitalization risk such as
during january 2021.
so in other words it is not like super
duper clear-cut for parents that you
know you desp you desperately want your
13 year old to get the vaccine
especially dose 2 right dose one doesn't
seem to be nearly as affected by these
uh these myocarditis and pericarditis
events uh but those two seems to have
some problems
okay well
la is just mandating it right because
the idea is that if you listen to the
government they can keep you safe if you
listen to the government they can always
keep you safe which is of course
why the the media keeps suggesting over
and over invariably
that
you must mask up your children now again
the evidence on masking for kids does
not exist there is no study done
anywhere that masking for kids
significantly lowers danger of
transmission among children why because
kids don't wear the masks properly
because kids associate outside of school
and because again kids are are generally
not in significant danger of
hospitalization and death from covid in
fact the stats tend to show that if
you're under the age of 18 there are
less risk of hospitalization in
ethimicova than if you're vaccinated in
40.
okay so
this idea that the government has to
mandate this stuff is just
disconnected from reality but again the
promise that has been made by the people
who are pushing for the cultural
dissolution of the united states and our
foreign policy retreat the case that
they make is they can protect you
forever which is why joe biden is now
going to push private businesses for
vaccine mandates
he apparently according to the new york
times is going to impose
new vaccination mandates as part of part
of a broad plan to put pressure on
private businesses federal agencies and
schools to enact stricter vaccination
and testing policies as the delta
variant continues to spread across the
united states now all of this is part
and parcel of a broader economic push
because the reality of course is that
the economy has been slowing now the
case that has been made by people on the
left is that the economy is slowing
because of delta is this according to
the feds at beige book according to the
wall street journal quote the us
economic recovery slowed and prices
continued rising over the summer as a
resurgence of kova 19 cases linked to
the delta variant led consumers to pair
back spending and persistent supply
chain problems hampered business the
federal reserve said in a report on
wednesday
the deceleration in economic activity
was largely attributable to a pullback
in dining out travel and tourism in most
districts reflecting safety concerns due
to the rise of the delta variant in new
york city for instance the rise of delta
forced the cancellation of summer events
such as the fancy foods show and the
auto show in minneapolis the commercial
real estate industry which had expected
to benefit from workers returning saw
those hopes dashed when firms postponed
plans in san francisco the residential
real estate market sagged slightly as
would be buyers put off their home
searches in part because of the delta
variant
now there is a difference in how states
are doing on this thing as i've noted
before the unemployment rates in red
states the top the best states for
unemployment in the united states right
now are almost universally red and the
worst states for unemployment in the
united states are almost universally
blue
and that's according to the bureau of
labor statistics
right now these states that are doing
the best in terms of unemployment are
nebraska utah new hampshire south dakota
idaho vermont alabama oklahoma montana
georgia kansas minnesota north dakota
wisconsin indiana iowa missouri okay of
the states that i just mentioned the
only ones that could be considered blue
like seriously blue are minnesota
and vermont that's it
all of the others are at the very least
purple or red leaning
and meanwhile if you go to the worst
states in terms of unemployment you're
looking at in order nevada new york new
mexico california new jersey hawaii
connecticut illinois d.c
okay every single one of those is a
solid blue state
that is not a coincidence it's because
it is not delta that is killing the
economy it is the forced restrictions
and panic driven nature of government
that is killing the economy by the way
even biden's own people are
acknowledging this so for example his
labor secretary
right walsh marty walsh says yeah these
lockdowns are just killing business
we need to continue to get people back
in the workplace we need to continue to
keep industry moving forward we can't
afford uh a shutdown like we had a year
ago or a year and a half ago now this
time i was in a different role i was the
mayor of boston back then and when we
shut down the economy or shut down the
city it was devastating to so many
businesses we just need to continue to
move one step in front of the other one
foot in front of the other the president
has a plan he's going to continue on his
plan the stock market for the most part
is doing great now every day still
moving forward so there's confidence
there uh wages are up but yes we're
dealing with a little bit of inflation
but but i think i think that we've never
lived through times like this we've
never had to recover from a pandemic
like this
the recovery is in many ways
economically speaking wildly
disproportionate to what is actually
going on with the disease
okay but but the idea here again is that
the problem the innate promise here is
that you have surrendered your your
country and you've surrendered your
values and you've surrendered your
liberties to people who are going to
protect you for all time which is why
now when they're coming up short on that
their answer is we have to crack down
harder we have to crack down harder now
you say to yourself wait
i surrender my liberty so you're gonna
crack down harder on me it's gonna be
worse for me yes but here is the
compensatory part the compensatory part
is they are going to pay you they're
going to give you money in the end as
always the final part of the democratic
program is just spend money just throw
cash at everything
the new york times admits as much the
new york times has an article today
about this 3.5 trillion dollar bill
which is just a pork barrel of garbage
and everlasting social benefits
right that's the social welfare benefits
they have this this article on it here
is the title of it from cradle to grave
democrats move to expand social safety
net cradle to grave and that's it
that's it
we are fat and we are stupid and we are
hooked up to an iv that is just a
dripping
apparently dehydrated cheetos into our
blood
and uh and we are just going to fatten
ourselves to death we're going to
surrender on the foreign front we're
going to destroy ourselves on the home
front but at least we'll have cradle to
grave everything at least we'll we'll
have brought all the resources home and
we will pay you to give up all of your
liberties
and you will be supported by this vast
bureaucracy by this incredible
government
according to the new york times when
congressional committees meet this week
to begin formally drafting democrats
ambitious social policy plan they'll be
undertaking the most significant
expansion of the nation's safety net
since the war on poverty in the 60s
devising legislation that would touch
virtually every area of american's life
from conception to aged infirmity
passage of the bill is anything but
certain there is some debate between the
so-called moderate faction of the
democratic party and the progressives
but the proposed legislation would be
transformative a cradle-to-grave
re-weaving of a social safety net frayed
by decades of expanding income
inequality is the new york times making
the case for why we need the government
to take care of us from the time we are
born until the time that we die and so
long as the government's doing that do
we really need anything else do we need
a system of common values do we need to
live with each other in comedy do we
need to have any tolerance for
dissenting points of view in fact there
can't be
dissenting points of view against a
god-like government that protects you
from death infirmity and fear and
poverty i mean if that government can do
all of those things what sort of dissent
should be tolerated or even or even
allowed under such a system
the pandemic loosened the reins on
federal spending says the new york times
prompting members of both parties to
support showering the economy with aid
it also uncorked decades-old policy
desires like expanding medicare coverage
or paid family and medical leave that
democrats contend have proved to be
necessities that the country has lived
through the coronavirus crisis
polls have shown for a long time these
issues to support american families were
important and were popular but all of a
sudden they become not a nice to have
but a must have said heather bushy a
member of biden's council of economic
advisors they're not going to pay for
any of this they're going to blow out
the deficits they're going to completely
undermine the american currency or
they're going to raise taxes radically
but again what this is about is
establishing that government is your
father government is your protector
government is the great sky god
and this goes all the way back to the
obama administration
when uh the when barack obama declared
in 2012 that the life of julia was to be
emulated i don't remember all this way
back nearly a decade ago it was widely
derided in 2012 he was widely mocked it
was seen as a major misstep by the obama
administration the obama campaign put
out a graphic and it showed what julia's
life would be like under mitt romney
versus what it would be like under obama
and every single element of julia's life
was a government program that was going
to give her something
if you went back and looked at the
program that julia espoused that was
espoused for jewelry for julia by the by
the obama campaign it talked about how
as a little girl julia would be given
all of these wonderful social benefits
and then as a young woman she'd be given
social and then as an old woman and then
in her death she'd be given benefit
this is the promise so the question is
is that a deal you're willing to make
right no future for the country
financially
in terms of values or culture
in terms of foreign policy no future for
the country but
we'll eat and drink
because tomorrow we're dead
as john maynard keynes once suggested in
the long run we're all dead so you know
that's just the way that it works
if you're willing to make that trade
then this biden administration is for
you if you're not
now would be an excellent time to push
back because there ain't going to be a
long time for a concerted period for us
to do so in the future alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content coming up soon is the
matt wall show it airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show